[موسيقى]
وهذه الصور
التينه من وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه حيث
يلتقي انتني بلنكن وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيلي ويبحثان ملف
ايران في واشنطن
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
عشرات المستوطنين يقتحمون بلده حوار جنوب
نابلس تحت حمايه جيش الاحتلال وفي القدس
الشرقيه والخليل واريحا في الضفه الغربيه
سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تهدم تسعه
مباني سكنيه بزعم البناء غير المرخص من
جفير يطلب استمرار عمليات الهدم في
المدينه خلال شهر رمضان رغم تحذيرات
الاجهزه الامنيه
[موسيقى]
مع اعلاني جروسي التوصل الى اتفاقات
ملموسه خلال زيارته لطهران ايران متفائله
بتفاهمات مع وكاله الطاقه الذريه لحل
القضايا العالقه بدء اجتماعات مجلس محافظي
الوكاله ومصادر دبلوماسيه تستبعد اصدار
قرار ضد ايران ومع تحركات اسرائيليه في
واشنطن وزير الدفاع الايراني يحذر تل ابيب
من عواقب اي عمل يستهدف بلاده
مع احتدام معارك الشرق الجيش الاوكراني
يتمسك بمواقعه في بخموت رغم تقارير عن
انسحاب
يقلل من اهميه المدينه ويقول ان سقوطها في
حال حدوثه لن يغير مسار الحرب والمعركه
تشعل خلافات فاجنر والجيش الروسي
في تونس ازمه المهاجرين الافارقه نحو مزيد
من التصعيد الامم المتحده تدين مواصفاتها
بحمله القمع ضد المهاجرين البنك الدولي
يعلق اطلاق الاستراتيجيه الخاصه بتونس
الاتحاد الافريقي يلغي مؤتمرا مقررا في
العاصمه التونسيه ووزير الخارجيه التونسي
يصف الازمه بالمفتعله
في لقاء خاص الرئيس الصومالي حسن شيخ
محمود يقول للجزيره ان بلاده لن تقبل ان
تكون ساحه لاي حرب بالوكاله ويؤكد ان
الحرب ضد حركه الشباب تحقق اهدافها بفضل
استراتيجيه متعدده الجوانب لا تعتمد على
المواجهه العسكريه وحدها
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا هدم سلطات الاسرائيليه
منازل للفلسطينيين في حي وادي الجوز في
القدس المحتله بدعوى بناءها دون ترخيص وقد
افادت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان وزير الامن
القومي اتمار بن جير طالب بمواصله سياسه
هدم المنازل خلال شهر رمضان المقبل وان
الشرطه تستعد لتنفيذ اوامره رغم تحذيرات
قادته اجهزه الامن والشرطه من مخاطر
اشتعار الوضع في القدس والضفه الغربيه
جراء ذلك لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
ما توقعاتكم لنهج سلطات الاحتلال في
الفتره القادمه سته وسبعون في المئه وقعوا
تصعيد سياسه هدم منازل الفلسطينيين بينما
توقع 12% توقف الهدم بسبب خلافات
اسرائيليه داخليه
عشر في المئه الى تراجع وترات الهدم نتيجه
ضغوط خارجيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلال اهل قضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد مرور شهر على الزلزال اليونيسف تقدر
عدد الاطفال النازحين في جنوب تركيا
وسوريا باكثر من 850 الفا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون ايضا تحالف المعارضه في تركيا
يعلن ترشيح كمال
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]
وطبعا
تنضم الينا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا جيفارا نقترب معك اكثر من المشهد
ما الذي يحدث
حتى الان حاله من التوتر الشديد تسود بلده
حواره وتحديدا عند مفرق سليمان الفارسي
وهو ما بين حواره وبلده بيتا القريبه على
الشارع الرئيسي وفق شهود العيان كان يمكن
ان يكون هناك مجزره هذه الليله بحق عائله
فلسطينيه عشرات من المستوطنين اقتحموا
البلده فجاه بزعم الاحتفال بما يسمى بعيد
المساخر اليهودي قاموا بمهاجمه سياره
لعائله فلسطينيه فيها ام واب واطفال القوا
عليها الحجاره من ثم قاموا باطلاق الرصاص
المباشر على السياره الاهالي قاموا على
الفور بالهجوم لحمايه العائله
المستوطنون لم يكتفوا تحت حمايه قوات
الاحتلال بذلك بل قاموا برش غاز الفلفل
على طفله صغيره لم تتجاوز من العمر 3
سنوات اصيب من العائله من الاهالي هناك
على الاقل خمسه فلسطينيين تم نقلهم الى
احدى المستوصفات القريبه الاصابات هي بغاز
الفلفل الغاز المسيل للدموع احد المصابين
ايضا اصيب بحجر مباشر في الراس مقابل من
قبل
المستوطنين بالطبع لو كان المشهد مغاير او
مختلف لكان جنود الاحتلال قاموا على الفور
باطلاق النار بحمايه حمايه المستوطنين وتم
الاعتداء بشكل مباشر على الفلسطينيين ولكن
الان الحمايه بالكامل
ما ارينا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
للمستوطنين طيب هل الوضع مستمر يعني هل ما
زال المستوطنون في داخل البلده
نعم بالفعل هم لا زالوا يتواجدون في
البلده تحت حمايه قوات الاحتلال يقومون
بالرقص بالغذاء بطريقه استفزازيه وفق
الاهالي وما اكدوه لنا قبل قليل يرددون
بالطبع الشعارات العنصريه التي اساسها
الموتى للعرب جاءوا من المستوطنات القريبه
وهذه المستوطنات كما هو معروف السي هي من
يسكنهم اشرس واكثر المستوطنين تطرفا ولكن
حتى الان جنود الاحتلال
يتواجدون بكثافه في بلده بالكامل ونعرف ان
حواره والاحداث فيها متواصله في خاصه بعد
المذبحه وحرق المنازل والمحال منذ عشره
منذ تسعه ايام تقريبا الى اليوم وقد نشهد
المزيد وهذا ما تحذر منه كل المؤسسات
الدوليه وحتى الخارجيه الامريكيه هو
الخشيه على هذه القرى وتحديدا بلده حوار
طبعا نتابع معك التطورات الوضع اولا باول
ثوره حدوثها حتى الساعه شكرا لك مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري من رام الله
وقد هدمت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اليوم
9 منازل سكنيه بزعن بنائها دون ترخيص في
القدس الشرقيه والخليل واريحا في الضفه
الغربيه ففي القدس الشرقيه هدمت سلطات
الاحتلال ثلاثه منازل لشقيقين وابن عمهما
من عائله طوطح في حي وادي الجوز وفي مدينه
الخليل جنوبيه الضفه هدم جيش الاحتلال
اربعه منازل فلسطينيه واغلق منزلا خامسا
ومحلا تجاريا كما هدمت قوه الاحتلال
منزلين شمال غربي مدينه اريحا وقد طالب
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي تامر بن
جفير باستمرار هدم منازل الفلسطينيين في
القدس حتى خلال شهر رمضان المقبل
يخشى الفلسطيني في القدس ان يصبح مشهد هدم
منزله امرا عاديا فلل البيت قصه تتجاوز
حدود الدقائق التي تستغرقها سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هدم ما بني في
سنوات من شرفه بيت قريب تطل الحاجه ام
عرفات على منازل ثلاثه من ابنائها بالاحرى
على ركامها كمان
مش قادره اتصرف مش قادره اتصور
20 سنه عايشين فيه
على الارض تنعكس مطالبه وزير الامن
القوميه الاسرائيلي لتمر بن كبير بتكثيف
عمليات الهدم واستمرارها حتى في شهر رمضان
المقبل فقد ازدادت وتيره الهدم واصبح
الاحتلال يهدم عده منازل لعائله واحده في
يوم واحد هذه اراضينا من 300 سنه لاجدادنا
ملك واحنا مهجرين من ال 48 من الاطمون من
القدس الغربيه احنا تجاره حالتنا ميسوره
عندنا بلا الغاد وعنا عماره غاده موجوده
لحد هلا غاده اذا بدهنش ايانا هون عشان في
رخصه بيوتنا غادي برخصه يرجعون عليهم يا
عمي
من البيت المهدم الى البيت المهجر نعود مع
العائله الى حارتها الاصليه في الشطر
الغربي من المدينه الذي هجرت منه عام 48
شارع واحد يفصل بين شطري القدس الواحده
وكثير من التاريخ لم تتغير معالم البيوت
الفلسطينيه كثيرا تغير من يسكنها فقط هذه
الفيلا تبعت سيدي الباشا احمد سعيد طوطاح
سيدي هادي العماره برضه بناها لاولاده
خمسه وسبعون عاما لم تمحو الاما ولا هي
انسى صاحب البيت حنينه اليه
تطلع
اخذوها
يا عم يرجعونه
تقول حشرجه الكلمات ان صاحب الملك يعيش
معذبا اما عند عتبه بيته او عند ركامه لكن
القدس
تستحق هذا الصبر
هي قصه تهجير الفلسطينيين من المدينه
واحلال المستوطنين مكانهم اذ لا يكادوا
ينسى الفلسطيني بيته الذي هجر منه في
الشطر الغربي حتى تهدم له اسرائيل بيته
الذي اقامه في احيائها الشرقيه هكذا تعود
القصه الى بدايتها الى النكبه الاولى
والمتواصله
نجوى الجزيره مدينه القدس
من القدس ينضم الينا ناصر الهدم رئيس
الهيئه المقدسيه لمناهضه التهويد مرحبا بك
سيد ناصر ماذا وراء تكثيف حمله هدم
المنازل في القدس
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم ولجميع
المشاهدين
حقيقه ربما المشهد اليوم في مدينه القدس
هو انتقام من مدينه القدس واهلها نتيجه
الصفات التي وجهت له منذ بدايه صعوده
كالوزير الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ دوله
الاحتلال والاكثر اجراما بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني الان نعيش نعم مرحله هي واضح
جدا ان الاحتلال يستخدم خلال ما يس
بالقانون
بيوت نعم بنيت بدون ترخيص ولكن الذي اوجد
هذا الظرف هو الاحتلال نفسه الاحتلال الذي
منع او جعل عمليه الحصول على رخصه بناء في
القسم الشرقي من مدينه القدس للمقدسيين
امرا شبه مستحيل وهذا وفق تقارير من داخل
بلديه الاحتلال لذلك اضطر المقدسيون الذين
راوا اراضيهم واراضي غيرهم تتحول للبناء
الاستيطاني اضطروا لان يبنوا على هذه
الاراضي ويعيش فيها راوا عائلاتهم تكبر
وليس هناك مكان لابنائهم ليعيشوا داخل
حدود المدينه في سياسه ممنهجه من قبل
سلطات الاحتلال لدفع المقدسيين للخروج
خارج حدود بلديه الاحتلال ويفقد بعد ذلك
هويتهم المقدسيه
واقامتهم الدائمه في المدينه وقدرتهم على
التوجه او التواجد في المدينه وفي كل
فلسطين المحتله لذلك نعم هو ظرف خلقه
الاحتلال اضطر اليه المقدسيون فيقاومون
المقدسيون
قرار وجودها لو قارننا بالارقام وتيره
الهدم الحاصله في حكومه نتنياهو هذه مع
الوتيره كما كانت تحصل في حكومات سابقه
كيف يمكن المقارنه
واضح ان هناك تصعيد كبير وتصاعد في
الارقام بشكل ملفت للنظر يبدو ان سلطات
الاحتلال ارادت ان تتجاوز كل العقبات
ويعني هنا يردني الامر الى طبيعه بنج فير
وربما حتى الحكومه الحاليه باكملها انها
لا تحسب حساب كثير ولا تعطي وزنا كبيرا
لراي الدول الغربيه للراي الدولي للقانون
الدولي للشجو والاستنكار وهي تريد ان ان
تحسم المعركه في مدينه القدس وتثبت سياده
وسيطر على المدينه لذلك نعم نرى تكثيف
عمليات الهدم في هذا العام ومنذ ومنذ ان
اصبحت هذه الحكومه قيد العمل في المدينه
المقدسه نرى انها تكثف من عمليات الهدم
كما قلت في انتقام من اهل مدينه القدس
وايضا في مسعى من اجل حسم المعركه
والانتقال الى مرحله جديده في هذا الموضوع
شكرا لك من القدس ناصر الهدمي رئيس الهيئه
المقدسيه لمناهضه التهويد
[موسيقى]
يوصل مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه اجتماعاته التي بداها اليوم في
فيينا وتستمر عده ايام ونقلت وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مصادر دبلوماسيه
قولها ان المجلس لم يصدر قرارا جديدا بشان
ايران هذا الاسبوع وقالت الوكاله على لسان
مديرها العام ان ايران وافقت على السماح
لها بالمضي قدما في اجراءات المراقبه
والتحقق من الانشطه النوويه من جهه قال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ان طهران
توصلت الى تفاهمات مع الوكاله خلال زياره
غروستي الاخيره يمكن ان تمهد لحل القضايا
العالقه
اجتماع دوري لمجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه
لا تختلف اجنده اجتماع اليوم عن سابقاتها
اذ يستحوذ برنامج ايران النووي خصوصا بعد
التفاهمات التي عاد بها رفيع الجروسيم
مدير عام الوكاله الدوليه من ايران معلنا
عن فصل جديد من العلاقه بين طهران
والوكاله الدوليه من خلال اتفاق لاعاده
تشغيل الكاميرات وانظمه المراقبه في عده
منشات نوويه ازلتها طهران العام الماضي
وايضا زياده وتيره عمليات التفتيش لمنشاه
فوردو حيث اكتشفت جزيئات يورانيوم مخصب
بنسبه تتجاوز 83 ومن الاشارات الايجابيه
التي تحدث عنها جروسى سماح ايران للوكاله
بالوصول الى المعلومات والاماكن التي
تريدها
عن اتفاق مع المسؤولين في طهران اثار سيلا
انتقادات في صفوف التيار المحافظ داخل
ايران منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
دافعت بالقول انها لم تتنازل ابدا عن
لاتها السابقه لم يطرح بتاتا مساله لقاء
مع اشخاص وعلماء نوويين ايرانيين ولم يكتب
اي نص بشان ذلك كذلك لاتفاق بشان تركيب
كاميرات جديده في المنشات النوويه ولم
يجري الحديث بشان ذلك اما فيما يتعلق
بزياده التفتيش في منشاه فوردو فهو اجراء
روتيني طوعي منصوص عليه في اتفاق الضمانات
بانه بعد رفع نسبه تخسيب اليورانيوم في
المنشاه الى 60% ينبغي زياده عمليات
التفتيش تقول ايران ان علاقتها مع الوكاله
لن تخرج عن متن اتفاق الضمانات وهو اتفاق
تبرمه الوكاله بشكل منفرد مع الدول
الاطراف في معاهده عدم الانتشار النووي
بهدف التحقق من التزامها استخدام
التكنولوجيا النوويه للاغراض السلميه فقط
تبني الوكاله ومجلس محافظيها احكامهم بمدى
التزام ايران بسلميه برنامجها النووي من
خلال التقارير تقدمها ايران نفسها الى
الوكاله الدوليه ومن تقارير يرفعها مفتش
الوكاله وفقا لعمليات المراقبه والتفتيش
لمنشات ايران النوويه او وفق معلومات
تقدمها اطراف ثالثه دول او منظمات وهذا
البنت تحديدا مثل هاجسا لربما تسخره دول
معاديه لايران تمرر من خلاله هواجسها
للوكاله الدوليه فبكثير من الريبه راى
الايرانيون زياره غروستي لتل ابيب الصيف
الماضي تقول طهران انها لن تسمح لاسرائيل
بالاساءه لعلاقاتها مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه وان على مجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه النائيه بنفسه عن صراعات
السياسه
انضم الينا من طهران الدكتور حسن احمد
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه طهران ومعنى من
واشنطن مارك نائب مساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الاسبق لشؤون نزع الاسلحه
النوويه مرحبا بكم دكتور حسن احمد يان هل
يمكن القول ان هناك تطابقا بين ايران من
جهه والوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه من جهه
اخرى في تفسير
التفهمات حول المرحله المقبله
مساء الخير طبعا يبدو لي ان هناك شيئا من
التفاهم لكن القول بان هناك اتفاق حول
قضيه محدده وهما اشير له وفقه تصريحات
السيد جروسي وهو غير دقيق لانه ان قرانا
البيان المشترك الصادر في نهايه الزياره
يقول بانه ايران ستقدم بشكل تطوعي وهذه
الكلمه مهمه اي انه مفتوح باب التفسير
لامامها
ما ما تحتاجه الوكاله للتحقق من انشطه
ايران النوويه
اذا
النقطه الثانيه
هل يتطابق مع ما التزمت به ايران
طبعا كما اسلفت هناك هناك فرق بين التفاهم
والاتفاق النقطه الاخرى لانه اساسا وفق
وفقا الايرانيين هناك
فرق يعني هناك باب مفتوح للمفاوضات في
القريب العاجل للتوصل لتفاهمات حول
الجانب الفني
للتفاهم العام الذي توصلت جانبا اليه اذا
هناك شيئا من يعني قطعيه فيما يقوله جروسي
هناك شيء من الانفتاح على الحوار في ايران
في الاطار العام نزعت فتيل ازمه اريد
افتعالها كما يرى الايرانيون نتيجه هذه
الزياره لكن الى ماذا ستؤول هذه الزياره
وما الذي ربما يتوصل اليه الجانبين في
المفاوضات التي ستاتي في القريب العاجل
بين الوكاله وايران ذلك امر ربما سيكون
اكثر تعقيدا لان هناك ق ضايا عالقه سابقا
وهناك تتعلق بالشفافيه التي تظهر ايران
اذا وفق وجهه النظر الايرانيه ما جرى حتى
الان في التفاهم الذي جرى التوصل اليه حتى
الان بين الوكاله وطهران هو نزع فتيل ازمه
هل توافق على هذه النظره
يس انا
فهذه امور تحصل عاده حيث انه عشيه اجتماع
لمجلس الوكاله تقوم ايران ببادره معينه او
من نوع ما للتعاون وهذه البادره تكون عاده
كافيه
من اجل تخطي هذا الاجتماع لمجلس الوكاله
بدون الخروج بقرار ينتقد ايران وهذا هو
هدف مقامات به ايران على ما يبدو ولكن
التفاصيل تبقى مبهمه وانا لست فعلا
متفائلا ان هذا الاتفاق بين المدير العام
كروسي وايران قد افضى الى شيء دسم جيد
انهم يتحدثون وانا ايران
كما قلت يعني جيده انهم يتحدثون ونحن
نتحدثون عن منشات ثلاث
كانت عقبه امام اي تقدم في مسار مفاوضات
فيينا باعتقادك العوده للحديث عن شمول هذه
المفاوضات بتفتيش ايا كان نوع هذا التفتيش
كيف من شانه ان ينعكس على مسار فيينا
انا
لا اعرف ان ايران قد وافقت على التعاون
بالنسبه الى هذه المرافق الثلاثه ما فهمته
هو ان هناك اعاده تركيب لبعض الكاميرات في
بعض
منشات النوويه الشغاله بالاضافه الى زياده
عدد التفتيشات بالنسبه الى تاثير ذلك على
خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه ربما هذا قد
يساهم في ازاله بعض العوائق لاعاده تفعيل
الخطه ايران كانت تقول انها طالبت بان
توقف الوكاله تحقيقاتها في هذه المنشاه
الثلاثه لكن الوكاله لا يمكن ان توقف
تحقيقاتها
وربما هناك بعض التلميح هنا الى ان ايران
ستتخلى عن هذا المطلب لكن هذا غير واضح
حتى الان ما رايك دكتور حسن
طبعا المواقع الثلاثه قضيه شائكه عام 2015
اتفق على ما يفتح هذا الموضوع نتيجه توقيع
الاتفاق النووي احد مطالب ايران في
المرحله الاخيره كانت اغلاق هذا الملف بعد
العوده للاتفاق النووي ان يترك مجالا
للتحقق ثم يغلق هذا الملف يبدو لي من
الراشح من الخطب وما اقرا في لدى الاطراف
الغربيه الاوروبيه بشكل محدد انه هناك
قبول للاطروحه الايرانيه لكن ما تطالب به
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ليس فقط
هذه المواقع الثلاث هناك ابعاد اخرى يعني
هناك تخصيب عالي النسبه في فوردو يراد
التحقق منه لذلك يبدو ان هناك قبول ايراني
لابداء شيئا من الشفافيه ايران تريد القول
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه انها
منفتحه على تضمين هذه الوكاله لكن ان تعود
ايران للشفافيه التي كانت سائده قبل
2019 فذلك سيحدث فقط عند العوده للاتفاق
النووي والا
دونها سوف لن تعود الى ايران الى تلك
النسبه من الشفافيه شكرا لك من طهران
الدكتور حسن احمد الشرق الاوسط في جامعه
طهران وشكرا للسيد مارك نائب مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الاسبق لشؤون نزع
الاسلحه النوويه ضيفنا
من جهه اخرى يلتقي وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيلي روندرمر خلال
زياره رسميه لوشنطن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ومسؤولين اخرين لبحث قضايا
ابرزها الملف النووي الايراني والقضيه
الفلسطينيه وذلك قبيل زياره مرتقبه لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي
الى تل ابيب خلال هذا الاسبوع لبحث ملف
ايران حسب مصادر مطلعه في تل ابيب
في المقابل قال وزير الدفاع الايراني محمد
رضا اشتياني ان اسرائيل تلجا لتنفيذ اعمال
تخريبيه بعد تاكد قادتها من عجزهم عن
القيام بعمليات علنيه اضاف اشتياني ان
تهديدات اسرائيل ليست سوى اوهام وحرب
نفسيه وانا طهران سوف ترد عليها متى
وحيثما رات ذلك ضروريا وقال ان وزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه صنعت 38 قطعه لمواجهه ما
سماها الاعمال التخريبيه التي تستهدف
المقر الصناعيه من قبل العدو حسب تعبيره
اضاف ان هناك خططا لصناعه صواريخ باليستيا
جديده ودقيقه يصل مداها 2000 كم
اما رئيس هيئه الاركان الايرانيه اللواء
محمد باقر فقال ان ايران اختبرت بنجاح
صاروخا باليستيا قادرا على استهداف قطع
بحريه متحركه وانا طهران تعمل حاليا على
انتاج هذا الصاروخ الذي يبلغ مداه 1500
كيلو متر ويحلق بسرعه عاليه واشار الى ان
امتلاك هذا النوع من السلاح يوفر الامن في
البحار المحيطه بايران الى مسافه تصل الى
الف كيلو متر
في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على الصاروخ
البالستي الذي اعلن الطهران اختباره ونسال
ضيفا عن موقعه واهميته في المنظومه
الصاروخيه الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان قيمه مدينه
بخموت رمزيه اكثر منها استراتيجيه او
عملياتيه اضاف انه اذا سقطت باخموت فهذا
لا يعني ان روسيا احدثت تغييرا جوهريا في
مجريات الحرب
بدوره قال مؤسس شركه فاجنر العسكريه
ان الشرطه العسكريه الروسيه اعاقت وصول
اشخاص انضموا حديثا لقواته الى مركز فاجنر
العسكري وانتقد بريجوجل مره اخرى نقص
الذخائر وحذر من انهيار جبهه
من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد الياس حنا
لماذا باعتقادك اختار زيلينسكي ان يبقي
على الدفاع على مدينه باخموت رغم الحديث
الغربي ولا سيما الامريكي عن انها معركه
رمزيه لا تعني شيء
اولا ال سي بالنسبه لاوكرانيا هي تدعم
مدينه مخمود بالرغم من الواقع الهجن حتى
الان ولكن هذا تدعيم قد يهدف الى ثلاث
احتمالات مهمه الانسحاب التكتيكي واعاده
التموضع بسبب الخسائر التي حصلت ان كان في
الجنوب الشمال وحتى في الشرق اثنين
التحضير الانسحاب كامل وشامل امن على
الاقل والانسحاب الى مدينه يسع مدينه
مدينه يعني قريبه تقريبا 12 شذى 12 كم غرب
هذه المنطقه وبناء خط دفاعي اخر ثلاثه هذه
المنظومه الدفاع عن بخموت ال سي هي تخدم
مصلحه معينه قد تاتي في مرحله لاحقه تقوم
على المبدا الذي يقول خساره المساحه
والارض لكسب الوقت والاستعداد لمرحله
لاحقه وهذا يعني بخموت ليست مهمه بالمعنى
الاستر اتيجي وهذا ما يقول عنه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي طيب ان كانت
استراتيجيا لا تغير في شيء لماذا هذا يعني
الاصرار الروسي على التقدم هناك باعتقادك
اولا هناك
سباق وجدل بين وزاره الدفاع
وممول شركه فاجنر من يكسب من يربح من يحقق
شيء وهذه الاتهامات المتبادله هذا اول امر
الامر الثاني
قد تعتبر مخموت بابا يفتح على
هذا يعني السيطره على الاقليم
ويعتبر اقليم الدمباز جزء اساسي وهو جوهره
التاجر الرئيس بوتين وهو قد ضمها مع
الاقاليم الاربعه هي باب اساسي ولكن اليوم
اذا تعثر على مخموت منذ اوغست الماضي حتى
الان ان تسقط مخمود فماذا يعني عن مدينه
سلبيانس وكراماتورسك التي تبعد تقريبا 50
كلم عن بخموت وهي اكبر بكثير من الصعوب
الاستيلاء عليها طيب في اطار ما ذكرته
عميد الياس حنا عن هذه التصريحات
المتبادله بين فاجنر او دعنا نقول تصريحات
فاغنر ضد الجيش الروسي وضد القاده
العسكريين الروس كيف يفهم استمرارها وعدم
حسمها من جانب الطرف الروسي
بدء الحرب
يخرق الاداء الروسي مبدا وحده القياده
يعني كان في بدايه حرب ثلاثه جيوش تقاتل
مع وحدات او قيادات مختلفه القوات
الشيشانيه مع رمضان
كاديروفين مع مع فاجنر والجيش التقليدي او
الجيش الرسمي الروسي لكل منهما اهداف
معينه وقياده معينه مختلفه تماما حتى
كاديروفين شكلها حلف ضد وزاره الدفاع حتى
مؤخرا عندما تعاون سيروفيكين القائد الذي
اخذ القياده في اوكرانيا
اطيح به واتي بغاريزموف رئيس الاركان فقط
لعدم اعطاء هذا الانتظار الاساسي لانه
يسعى الى دور سياسي في المرحله القادمه
شكرا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس البنك الدولي ديفيد ملبس ان
البنك اوقف عمله مع تونس بعد تصريحات
الرئيس قيس سعيد بشان المهاجرين وفي مذكره
موجهه لموظفيها
عمل الشركه مع تونس مؤقتا وارجا اجتماع
مجلسه الذي كان مقررا لاحقا في مارس اذار
حتى اشعار اخر وقال ملبس ان البنك الدولي
يعتبر الخطوات التي اعلنتها الحكومه
التونسيه لحمايه ودعم المهاجرين واللاجئين
خطوه ايجابيه وسيراقب تاثيرها
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نيد
برايس ان بلاده قلقه من تصريحات الرئيس
التونسي بشان المهاجرين الافارقه
والاعتقالات التي استهدفتهم واحث برايس في
احاطته اليوميه السلطات التونسيه على
الوفاء بالتزاماتها فيما يتعلق بحمايه
حقوق اللاجئين والمهاجرين
من جانبه اعرب استيفاندو جاريك المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده عن قلق
المنظمه الدوليه ازاء ما سماها حمله القمع
المتزايده التي يتعرض لها المهاجرون في
تونس
ان الامم المتحده تدين خطاب العنصريه
وكراهيه
الاجانبون للغايه بشان موجه الاعتقالات
التعسفيه التي شهدناها خاصه تلك التي
استهدفت المعارضه السياسيه والمجتمع
المدني والصحفيين وبشان حمله القمع
المتزايده ضد المهاجرين وهو امر مثير
للقلق ايضا لا يسعني الا ان اقول اننا
نادين دون تحفظ كل التصريحات التي تنم عن
كراهيه الاجانب والعنصريه
اتهم وزير الخارجيه تونسي نبيل عمار
اطرافا داخليه وخارجيه لم يسميها بافتعال
وتاجيج ما وصفها بالحمله التي تستهدف تونس
وقال عمار ان السلطات التونسيه اتخذت
اجراءات لدعم المهاجرين بصفه قانونيه على
اراضيها وتعمل على حمايتهم
فما عديد الاطراف
لها جندات مختلفه عندها مصلحه اللي هي
عندها مصلحه باشا تهيج شويه الامور موجوده
لداخل والترجمه بارت
جوانب اجانب
اخرى معناتها هذا شيء واضح انتما تعرفوا
الهجره معناتها فيها برشا معناتها
ومصالح ماديه ماهيش
اللي عنده مصلحه في التجاره هاديه بالبشر
هي التجاره بالبشر في اخر المطار
وقد رفض وزير الخارجيه التونسيه بيلعب
عمار اتهام بلاده بالعنصريه ووصف هذه
الاتهامات بالمضحكه قائلا ان حل مساله
الهجره يجب ان يكون جماعيا
الهجره الموضوع هذا يفوت بلد واحد تونس
بالذات هو مرتبط معنتها بشبكات عالميه وهو
موضوع يهم
عديد الدول في العالم اكثر من غيرها والحل
ديما كيما تقول تونس الحل منجم يكون كان
بالتعاون وبالتشاور مع جميع الاطراف
المعنيه والاتهامات اللي موجه لتونس اللي
هي معروفه في العالم كبلد مضياف وبلد
يستقبل بلد عاشت فيها عديد الحضارات انه
اليوم تونس مع توتنهام بالعنصريه هذا
الشيء معناتها
ما يستقيمش وربما مضحك شويه
معنى من تونس مراسل والجزيره حافظ مريبه
حافظ ماذا في اخر ردود الفعل التي سجلت
على هذه المواقف الدوليه
نعم في الحقيقه لعل وزير الداخليه الذي
وزير الخارجيه عفوا نبيل عمار الذي كنا
نستمع لكلامه لخص موقف تونس بخصوص هذا
الجدل وكنت قد حضرت المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
عقده اليوم اكد ان الاتهامات التي طالت
تونس بانها دوله عنصريه هي اتهامات وصفها
بالمضحكه وقال ان تونس ترفضها جمله
وتفصيلا وقلنا تونس ترحب بالمهاجرين وهي
من الدول التي على مدى تاريخها استقبلت
المهاجرين وقال ان هنالك قوانين تنظم
الهجره تعود الى عام
1968 السلطات تريد تطبيق هذه القوانين
وقال ان السلطات تريد حمايه المهاجرين على
اراضي تونس نبيل عمار اتهم اطرافا رفض
تسميتها بانها تقف وراء اختلاق هذه الازمه
على حد تعبيره وحتى
وقال انها ازمه او جدل ما كان له ان يكون
قال ان السلطات التونسيه تعمل على تسهيل
اقامه المهاجرين هنا في تونس وقد اتخذت
واعلنت عده اجراءات الحكومه يوم امس من
شانها تسهيل حياه الطلبه السارقه من دول
جنوب الصحراء في تونس
وغيرهم من اجل مزاوله دراستهم وحتى العيش
والعمل هنا في تونس على حد التعبيره قال
ايضا ان السلطات لن تتسامح مع كل من يثبت
في انه اعتدى على مهاجرين او او اعتدى على
حقوقهم او اعتدى عليهم بالعنف وغير ذلك
وقال ايضا ان من حقي من يريدون مغادره
تونس ان يغادروها طوعا والعوده الى
بلدانهم ولكن ولكنه اكد على ان تونس دوله
ليست عنصريه وهي ترحب بالجميع على اراضيها
وفق ما يقتضيه القانون على حد التعبير نعم
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس صومالي حسن شيخ محمود ان
الحكومه في مقديشو اعتمدت استراتيجيه
عسكريه وفكريه واقتصاديه لمحاربه حركه
الشباب وخلال مقابله مع الجزيره اكد
الرئيس الصومالي ان هذه الاستراتيجيه تحقق
اهدافها
الحل لمعضله حركه الشباب ليس عسكريا فحسب
لقد اعتمدنا الخيار العسكري خلال الاعوام
الخمسه عشر الاخيره نحن الان نعتمد
استراتيجيه من ثلاثه جوانب اولا العسكري
وهو معتمدناه في الماضي اما الثاني فهو
المواجهه الفكريه مع الحركه فحركه الشباب
تدعي انها حركه جهاديه قائمه على تعاليم
الدين الاسلامي مع العلم ان مئه في المئه
من الشعب الصومالي مسلمون لذلك نعتمد الان
على علماء مسلمين الصوماليين لتوعيه الناس
فكريا من هذه الناحيه وخلال مؤتمر في
مقديشو اصدر العلماء فتوى بان افعال حركه
الشباب لا تمت للاسلام بالصله اما الجانب
الثالث فهو حرب اقتصاديه من خلال تجفيف
جميع منابع تمويل حركه الشباب هذه هي
استراتيجيتنا لمحاربه الحركه وهي تحقق
اهدافها
وفي شان اخر قال الرئيس الصومالي في
مقابلته مع الجزيره ان الحكومه الصوماليه
لا تريد حروب وكاله على ارض الصومال كما
اكد ان مقديشو تنسج علاقاتها مع جيرانها
وشركائها مما يتوافق مع مصالحها وليس من
اجل عداوه اي دوله اخرى
نحن في الصومال لدينا رؤيه للتعامل مع
جميع الشركاء لقد وضعنا سياسه خارجيه على
قاعده صفر اعداء وحمله الانتخابيه كانت
قائمه على الشعار صومال يعيش في سلام
داخليا ومع بقيه العالم لا نريد للصومال
ان يكون ارضا لحروب بالوكاله يخوضها
اصدقائنا على ارضنا وعليه نتعامل مع كل
دوله على حده وبشكل منفصل بناء على
مصالحنا المشتركه وليس من اجل التحالف ضد
اي دوله اخرى
بعد مضي شهر على الزلزالين الكارسيين في
تركيا وسوريا قالت اليونيسف ان اكثر من
850 الف طفل ما يزالون نازحين بعد
اضطرارهم لترك منازلهم المتضرره او
المدمره وقالت المنظمه ان عدد الاطفال
الذين قتلوا او اصيبوا خلال الزلزال وما
اعقبه لم يتاكد بعد لكن من المرجح ان يصل
الرقم الى عده الاف واشارت المنظمه الى ان
تاثير الزلازل على اطفال المنطقه
وعائلاتهم كان كارثيا حيث ترك مئات الالاف
في ظروف بائسه وفقدت العديد من العائلات
منازلها وتعيش الان في اماكن ايواء مؤقته
وقالت المديره الاقليميه لليونيسف في
اوروبا واسيا الوسطى افشان خان انه من
الضروري بذل كل ما في الوسع لمساعده
العائلات على اعاده بناء حياتها وتوفير
الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي للاطفال واعادتهم
الى التعلم في اسرع وقت ممكن وتوفير بعض
الاستقرار وسط الفوضى
في تركيا اعلنت احزاب المعارضه للمشاركه
فيما يسمى بالطاوله السداسيه ترشيح زعيم
حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمالكيشدار اوغلو
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله عقب الاعلان
قال كيليجار اوغلو ان احزاب الطاوله
السداسيه ستقود تركيا بالمشوره والتفاهم
عبر ما سماه بالنظام البرلماني المعزز
معنى من اسطنبول الدكتور سعيد الحاج
الباحث في الشان التركي والعلاقات الدوليه
مرحبا بك دكتور سعيد الحاج ما هي نقاط
القوه وايضا نقاط الضعف لدى
مساء الخير تحياتي لا شك انه من المتوقع
دائما في اي دوله ان يكون زعيم المعارضه
هو الذي يترشح امام زعيم الحزب الحاكم او
التحالف الحاكم لكن هذا لم يكن يحصن
تاريخيا كثيره في تركيا ربما دفعت لهذا
الامر اعتقد ان ابرز نقاط قوه
انه اولا وراءه ماكينه حزبيه قويه واكبر
احزاب المعارضه الشعب الجمهوري ثم هو يجمع
معه خمسه احزاب اخرى ثم ثالثا لديه
امكانيه للتفاهم مع احزاب اخرى تحديدا حزب
الشعب الديمقراطي وقد تتجه اليه اصوات
الناخب الكردي بين مزدوجين فضلا عن اللغه
التي يعني نسجها خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه وهناك رغبه لدى شرائح ربما في
الشعب التركي تحديدا فئه الشباب ربما
لديهم رغبه في التغيير وما الى ذلك كل هذه
الامور قد تكون نقاط قوه وخصوصا المشهد
الذي ظهر به اليوم وراءه خمسه احزاب اخرى
من مختلف التوجهات الاسلاميه المحافظه
القوميه والليبراليه لكن اعتقد ايضا ان
هناك نقاط ضعف لا يمكن الاستهانه بها
وربما هي تكمن في هذه الطاوله السداسيه
يعني كان يفترض بطاوله من مختلف التوجهات
والمشارب ان تقدم مرشحا توافقيا غير فاقع
سياسيا يمكن ان ياخذ اصوات او يقنع شرائح
انتخابيه من مختلف التوجهات قد اصدار اغلق
شخص فاقع سياسيا ورئيس المعارضه كما ذكرت
لديه ارث الشعب الجمهوري لعقود طويله
ثانيا يبدو وكانه فرض نفسه فرضا على
الطاوله السداسيه الصور اليوم لدى اعلانهم
مرشحا توافقيا لم تكن فقط اكشنر التي
ذهبت في في مغاضبه ربما مع هذه الطاوله
فقط غير سعيده معظم رؤساء الاحزاب الاخر
الاخرين لم يكونوا يعني سعيدين هنا مستخدم
قوه حزبه بالتالي ثم انه اخيرا دكتور سعيد
هذا هذه الاجواء هذه الاجواء كيف تنعكس
على وحده المعارضه خلف هذا المرشح في
المرحله المقبله
انا اعتقد ان هذا هو ربما السؤال الاهم
لانه يفترض اذا كانت يريد ان ينجح يفترض
بكل هذه الاحزاب ان تعمل بنفس الماكينه
النشطه ربما في الدعايه الانتخابيه في
الحملات الانتخابيه وهذا الان غير متوقع
من جهه لانه فعلا حتى رؤساء الاحزاب غير
السعيدين بالمواد الثانيه عشر التي اعلنت
اليوم ثانيا ليس مضمونا بل انا اتوقع انه
كثير من الناخبين المنضمين للاحزاب
الاسلاميه والمحافظه وغيرهم ربما حتى لو
كان رؤساء احزان في مرشحون وقد لا يذهبون
لترشيحه لانه النقطه الاساس ان المرشح
التوافقي المثالي للمعارضه كان يفترض ان
يطمئن شرائح انتخابيه قد تكون غير راضيه
عن الرئيس اردوغان لكن هنا
للشعب الجمهوري اعتقد انه ليس شخصا مطمئنا
لكثير من هذه الشرائح ولذلك انا اعتقد ان
اردوغان الليله قد يكون احد السعيدين بهذا
الاختيار لانه هو تقريبا هو اضعف شخصيات
المعارضه في مواجهه اردوغان من هذه
الزوايا اشكرك من اسطنبول الدكتور سعيد
الحاج الباحث في شان التركي والعلاقات
الدوليه
تستمر حالات التسمم في مدارس الفتيات في
ايران منذ نحو ثلاثه اشهر وتتحدث تقارير
رسميه عن تسمم مئات الطالبات بغازات سامه
وهو ما ادى الى حاله من الخوف بين اهالي
الطلاب وقد فتحت السلطات التحقيقا ووصف
المرشد الايراني هذه الحوادث بانها جريمه
لا تغتفر داعيا الى محاسبه الفعلين
حالات التسمم في مدارس الفتيات تشغل
الشارع وتثير مخاوف المواطنين في ايران
مذعورا يحاول هذا الاب الوصول لابنته بعد
سماعه نبا تسمم فتيات في مدرستهن
الابتدائيه
نرجس ام لطفلتين تحجم عن ارسالهما الى
المدرسه رغم التطمينات التي وصلتها من
المعلمين وتقول ان حياتهما اهم من التعليم
فقد الشعر اخشى على ابنتي من التسمم لذلك
لن ارسلهما الى المدرسه حتى تتضح الصوره
وينتهي هذا الكابوس
حاله التسمم الاولى كانت في مدينه قم
نهايه نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي ثم طالت
عشرات المدارس في اغلبيه محافظات البلاد
فاصيب مئات الطالبات السلطات استنفرت
وشكلت لجنه تحقيق من وزاره الصحه والتعليم
والاستخبارات ووصف المرشد الايراني اعمال
التسميم بالجريمه التي لا تختفر منهم
تاكيد اؤكد على ضروره متابعه هذه المساله
بجديه تامه انها جريمه كبيره لا تغتفر لا
شك في ان هناك من يقف هذه الجرائم ويجب
على الاجهزه الامنيه ان تتابع الموضوع
وتكشف عن العناصر الرئيسيه التي تقف
وراءها وتحاسب الجناس لحد الان لا توجد
روايه رسميه واحده عن طبيعه السمب
المستخدم بينما تفحص وزاره الصحه عينات
مشبوهه منه ويقول اطباء انه غاز طيار يسبب
اعراضا ليست خطيره
نعيش حاله طارئه في المستشفى حيث كثفنا
عدد الممرضين والغينا الاجازات لا نعرف
طبيعه الماده السامه بدقه لكنها تسببت في
حالات غثيان تصف السلطات الاحداث بانها
مؤامره يقف وراءها الاعداء
وانها تهدف للناشر الرعب في الشارع لكن
يحذر متابعون من ان تتحول الى ازمه جديده
في جمهوريه اسلاميه لم تشفى بعد من
تداعيات احتجاجات كانت الشد في تاريخها
لغز طبيعه السم والغموض بشان الفاعلين
يلفان حاله التسمم بمدارس الفتيات في
ايران وطالما بقيت هذه المستشفيات تستقبل
مزيدا من الفتيات التي تعرضنا للتسمم تبدو
السلطات معنيه بتقديم اضاحات عاجله من اجل
عوده الطالبات الى المدارس
وانهاء حاله الخوف فيها عمر هواش الجزيره
طيرا
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى اعلان ايران عن تجربه ناجحه
لصاروخ باليسيا متطور ما هو هذا الصاروخ
الجديد وما هي مواصفاته وما قيمته في
منظومات التسلح الايرانيه بحسب رئيس هيئه
الاركان اللواء محمد باقر فان الصاروخ
البالستي الذي تعمل طهران على انتاجه
حاليا يبلغ مداه 1500 كيلومتر وهو قادر
على التحليق بسرعه عاليه ووفق هيئه
الاركان الايرانيه فان الصاروخ الجديد
يوفر الامس في البحار المحيطه بايران الى
مسافه تصل الى الف كيلو متر فضلا عن
قدراته على استهداف قطع بحريه متحركه فان
حاملات الطائرات ايضا لن تكون في مامن من
هذا النوع من الصواريخ حتى وان كانت تلك
الحاملات على بعد 1500 كيلومتر وسبق
لايران انكشفت سابقا عن انتاج منظومات
صاروخيه مختلفه من ابرزها منظومه 15
التي تم اختبارها في نوفمبر عام 2019
وتستطيع هذه المنظومه اعتراض سته اهداف في
وقت واحد وتدميرها بما في ذلك الطائرات
الحربيه والمسيره في نطاق 120 كم باستخدام
ثلاث منصات اطلاق سعه كل واحده اربع
صواريخ من طراز صياد اثنان وصياد ثلاثه
الايرانيه
ايران التي بدات تطوير منظومتها التسليحيه
منذ حربها مع العراق باتت اليوم تمتلك
واحده من كبريات ترسانات الصواريخ
الباليستيه في المنطقه وهي مقسمه الى
ثلاثه اصناف رئيسيه منظومه صواريخ
باليستيه قصيره المدى واهمها مجموعه
صواريخ زلزال واحد واثنين وثلاثه التي
يتراوح مداها بين 150 و 250 كيلومترا ثم
الصاروخ الاحدث في هذه الفئه وهو صاروخ
فاتح 110 بمدن يصل الى 300 كيلومتر اما
الفئه الثانيه فهي منظومه صواريخ باليستيه
متوسطه المدى وقد بدات مع اعتراز شهاب
ثلاثه بمدن يتجاوز 1000 كيلومتر ثم شهر
ثلاثه دال ولاحقا صاروخ عاشوراء الباستي
الذي يبلغ مداه 2500 كيلومتر وثالثا
منظومه صواريخ باليستيه بعيده المدى
واهمها صاروخ شهاب اربعه بمدى 3000 كيلو
متر وهو صاروخ مهم تعكف ايران على تطويره
بشكل متسارع بعد ذلك اعلنت ايران انتاج
صاروخ سجيل بمدى 2000 كيلو متر وهو الاول
الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب باضافه الى
صاروخي خليج فارس وحوت المضادين للسفن حول
هذا الموضوع معنا من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بك لواء فايز ما قيمه هذا الصاروخ
الجديد الذي اعلن عن اجراء تجربه عليه
يعني هو احد الصواريخ التي اعلن عنها خلال
السنوات الماضيه هناك طيف واسع من
الصواريخ
المنطلق الاساسي
لانتاج الصواريخ هو كان الحاجه الماسه بعد
التهديدات الامريكيه
والتقييم الايراني لقدراتها مقابل القدرات
الامريكيه فاختار الطريق
تمكنها وتؤهلها من خوض حرب استنزاف مؤلمه
طويله الامد فكانت البدائل المتاحه
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره التقرير قدم
بعض المعلومات حول القدرات الايرانيه لكن
عندما نتحدث عن الصواريخ البحريه نتحدث عن
الصواريخ المجنحه وليس الصواريخ
الباليستيه ولديها مجموعه من هذه الصواريخ
منها ما يصل الى الف كيلو متر ابو مهدي
المهندس او خليج هرمز او
عفوا مضيق هرمز او الخليج فارس الى غير
ذلك هذه الصواريخ منها ما يعمل بيع الطاقه
الحراريه منها ما يعمل توجيهنا داري توجيه
تلفزيوني او من خلال اشعه الليزر
الحديث عن دقتها في البدايه كانت 500 متر
ثم بدات تدرج صعودا حتى اخر تقرير كان
خمسه الى ثمانيه متر هذه الصواريخ كما
اشارت تقرير فرض صوتيه من ثلاثه الى خمس
اضعاف منها صواريخ ذكيه الذي يجري
تجري التجارب عليه ويصل مداه الى 1500
كيلو متر هذا الصاروخ تحديدا ما اهميته ما
قيمته في منظومه الدفاع او في المنظومه
العسكريه الايرانيه ولماذا سيستخدم
اذا كانت المعلومات التي قدمت معلومات
دقيقه موثقه واستنادا عليها تعتبر اي
سفينه متحركه ضمن مدى الف الى 1500 كيلو
متر هدفا يمكن الحاق الضرر به ما لم يكون
محصنا من خلال منظومات الدفاع ضد الصواريخ
والمشكله هذه الصواريخ تطلق من ثلاثه
منصات من اولا تطلق من الجو تطلق من منصات
اطلاق ارضيه تطلق من منصات عائمه وتطلق من
تحت الماء وبالتالي اذا كانت المعلومات عن
هذه التقنيه المتطوره فبالتالي يجب على
كافه السفن
الغربيه سواء الاسطول الخامس او الاسطول
السادس
اي قطع بحريه بريطانيه غربيه عليها ان
تاخذ ذلك بعين الحذر والجدي المطلقه في
حال نشوب اي صراع لان كما قلت لك بعض
المعلومات والتقارير اذا كانت دقيقه ان
درجه الخطا صفر الذي اعلن عنه اليوم
هل عمليا دخل مرحله العمل وضع في حيز
العمل ام انه مازال يخضع للتجارب
لا بناء على التقارير الايرانيه وقائد
البحريه هذا الصاروخ بدا تفعيله في عام
2019 ودخل الخدمه فعليا وفي اخر مناوره
اجريت في بحر عمان قيل انه تم اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ واصابه الاهداف المتحركه بدقه
متناهيه اذا بناء على التقارير الوارده
وتصريحات المسؤولين الايرانيين هو الان
قيد الخدمه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من عمان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز
الدويري
[موسيقى]
احترق مسكنه كما احترق دكاني اخذت النيران
كل شيء مني كل شيء هذا ما يقوله مامون
جوهر اللاجئ من مسلم الروهينغ اما سليم
الله وهو اب لسته اطفال فيقول لم استطع
انقاذ اي شيء كل شيء احرق وتحول الى رماد
كثيرون بلا منازل لا اعرف ماذا سيحدث لنا
يلخص الرجلان مشهد ما بعد احتراق اكثر من
2000 من خيام اللاجئين ومساكنهم الخشبيه
في مدينه كوكس بازار جنوب شرقي بنجلاديش
الى هناك فرق اكثر من مليون من مسلمي
الروهينغا هربا من اعمال قمع قالوا ان
السلطات من المال برستها عليهم هي فرصه
للتضامن وتذكر وتذكر محنه فارلين من واقع
مؤلم في بلادهم الى اشكال متكرره من
المعاناه والامل كل الامل ان ينعم الجميع
بالام شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه ننتقل
بكم الان الى جوله منتصف الليل يرافقكم
فيها عبد القادر عياد وسيله علميه وانا
اشكركم على متابعتنا الى اللقاء